so the number we're talking about now is
60 now it's quite a big number so you
may not meet it all the time when you do
use it a lot when telling the time looks
of course there are 60 seconds in a
minute 60 minutes in an hour
but why 60 why this random number 60
well it all goes back to the Babylonians
thank you Babylonians
because what they wanted back then is a
very nice number that divides quite
easily so if you think about the number
six think what goat what divides it
cleanly one course two three four five
and six in fact it's the smallest number
that's divisible by all of these well
why is this important because you can
take half of it you can take a quarter
of it you could take a fifth of it you
could take a third of it you can divide
60 up in a lot of ways so if you're
cooking in this base you can cook with
lots of fractions of that so if you
don't want to cook a whole meal you can
cook half a meal or a third of a meal or
you know your things like that again if
you're telling time you can have quarter
an hour you can have twenty minutes you
can have half an hour you can have
three-quarters of an hour it all divides
six do very nicely and when you don't
have computers you need a number that
you can divide nicely so you get nice
round numbers at the end of it so
because they're easier to work with so I
mean sixteen wide if 60 so nice why do
we use ten well the idea is that we use
ten because we have ten fingers so you
can just count along as you're a child
you'd count one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten well what's its
thought is that the Babylonians actually
counted into 60 on two hands they would
use each knuckle on one hand to count 12
and then count the number of 12 on the
other so you'd go 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 one set of 12 and then you do it
again 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 2 sets
of 12 and again and again until you get
5 sets of 12 which is 60 highly
divisible and you can use it on your
hands so when the Babylonians were
working with this number 60 there were
also very good astronomers and what they
found is that the
year is pretty much 360 days so that's
the length of time it takes for the
earth to go a full circle and that's
what why the the circle is divided up
into 360 degrees and further each degree
is then divided up into 60 minutes you
can have an arc minute which is a
sixtieth of a degree and that further is
then 60 seconds 60 arc seconds of that
60 minute like I say it's very very
difficult I mean you could write well
there's 57 we what we use it two numbers
for a Babylonian to write 57 they would
have to write 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
it's a lot easier to write like that
than that so these are how they drew
their numbers because they had little
stylus that they would hit into clay and
the stylus had a triangular end so their
stylus would look something like that
and so when they were doing ones they'd
use the tip and go 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 all the
way up to 10 and a 10 that turn the
stylus on the side and create one of
those shapes so each one of those is 10
each one of these is a 1 and so there we
have 50 exactly which really goo 1 2 3 4
5